this is a production of cornell
university
all right we are up in northern new york
in the thousand islands region
uh looking at some vines today and
behind me we have marquette
and i've probably talked about marquette
in class
it's a minnesota cultivar uh
it's red makes quite nice wines we've
actually got the start of
raisin here so we can see the start of
grape ripening
today is uh july 30th i think it is
so marquette's a very early cultivar
because it has some vitus riparian in it
so we are actually seeing some berries
starting to turn purple
as you can see and they're softening too
so if i
squeeze the darker berries they're very
soft
the green berries are still very hard
so start of raisin in here but what i
really wanted to show you
was that we have a lot of winter damage
in this vineyard
and uh when we've had a really cold
event
through the winter it's a really good
time to go back and look at site
selection
and look at well what could i have
learned or what could i do better
so behind me here we have a slight
uphill slope
and the vines look look pretty decent
we've got pretty good
growth uh coming along here some nice
shoots
down to about my waist or so this is on
high wire cordon
but if we turn around and walk this way
and head down the hill you can actually
see
a fair amount of damage so
here for example uh you can see very
small berries that uh they are purple
but they're not
ripening so what's happened here is that
this vine has started to grow
but there was trunk damage that wasn't
terribly visible
at the time so the vine starts to grow
looks okay
and then we see some damage like this
and you can actually see it looks like
the trunk is going to split
right along here and so we're going to
lose at least the top
part of this vine uh the good news is
the vine will not need to be replanted
we have some pretty good uh suckers down
here or renewals
so what uh we can do is just cut off the
trunk
and then tie one of these up and they
will become the new
vine so no need to replant here
but as we walk downhill you can see
that things actually get a little bit
worse we've got some decent vines
and then here we come to a vine that has
nothing alive on the top
but again just some suckers here for
trunk renewal
what this grower really needs to do is
thin these out so right now we've got
one two
three four five six seven eight nine
suckers
on this vine and if we've got nine
suckers
they're all gonna grow to say about this
height if we thin that down to maybe two
suckers then the carbohydrates in the
roots
are going to go into those two suckers
only and we'll get really good growth
and get this at least up to the top wire
as a vine replacement for the following
year
so again no need to replant but it's
going to be a couple of years until
these vines look
reasonably normal and then again if we
just had a little further down the hill
we can see more and more damage here on
both the left side
and the right side and what i want to
show you is at the very bottom here is
we hit a bowl in the vineyard
and we can actually see we've had some
drainage problems here
too so if you look down here uh
no vines they've lost them in a previous
year
and then there are some tire tracks
right down here on the ground
some considerable divots which shows us
that it's been very very
wet here and there's no tile drainage
under this
vineyard so there's nowhere for the
water to go so when it's wet
it just cools here so water pools here
cold air pools here and so that's why
there's no
vines you can see on this neighboring
vine over here
we've got some very small suckers uh and
even if we thin these out they're not
going to do terribly well
so this is when you can go back and
really look at your vineyard design
and look at what could have been done
better in this situation i think this
low area
definitely needs some tile drainage and
probably really shouldn't have been
planted
because it's just too low in topography
compared to the rest of the vineyards
and the cold air really pools here at
this low
point so after a cold winter good time
to pick out when you've made some
problems and vineyard design
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu